i married a mexican y'all i'm the only
person in my house who don't speak
spanish my white friends aren't a latina
before i go dude just [ __ ] learn
spanish put a little effort in and learn
spanish how hard can it be i'm all [ __ ]
i am 38. i struggle with english at
times
like my women like my checks so make
sure that it's there keep it real and
make them stand out like comedienne
boys goes dude dude poppy deal with a
latina bro you know why because they're
fun and they're spicy you know what
spicy means they're [ __ ] that's what
that means
i decided to go on a keto diet you know
what keto is keto is a diet where you
can't eat mexican food that's the diet
mama what are you doing i know you know
i'm on keto lebron look taquitos it's
keto [ __ ] are we going to eat bean
cheese bean cheese bean cheese mint
cheese i'm just going to carb load year
round we're all going to be built like
armadillos the other thing you should
know about dana mexican nobody told me
this there's many flaming hot cheetos
all over your house
[Music]